yeah so i'm a senior data scientist at
parkmed and i'll talk about park med in
a second
i do have a background in biomedical
engineering and robot and surgical
robotics
and before pacman i worked a bit in
research in deep learning and then at
the bank
here in the netherlands
so it's a bit of fintech
and now i work at pakmet so pakmet is an
amsterdam-based startup we are we just
moved to a beautiful office in the pipe
it was founded in 2015 and we are about
30 employees right now and we are a mix
of engineers data scientists but also
former or current doctors
and we also expanded with a bit of a
legal team
and so on and what we do
is we developed ai
driven or machine learning driven
decision support tools for the intensive
care
um and is something that i'm going to
talk to you
about today
before we start so
i want to to answer this question
um
why are there so many machine learning
models developed in literature
but so few implemented in practice now
this applies to many areas but
particularly
in healthcare
uh and it's a big problem right because
okay so many cool things uh are being
developed are being researched but then
actually you go to a hospital and how
many times have you been treated with a
machine learning power software probably
very few times
um this is one of the one of the many
papers that tries to address this
problem um
and
one of the things that is highlighted is
how
the lack of ability to demonstrate the
fact that these models are safe and uh
and effective is basically hindering um
the the the spread
in practice of these models
and one of the main ways in which we can
try and actually
enhance this process is by making sure
that these models can be
surveilled their calibration is
monitored uh
having a robust infrastructure that
makes us able to be sure that the model
is doing what it's supposed to do over
time when the model is in production
this applies to every field i can think
of but particularly when the life of
patient is on the line
so today i'm going to give you a quick
introduction to pacma critical which is
our
flagship product for the intensive care
and then i will explore three main
challenges um that we face when
implementing machine learning for life
and death situations in intensive care
and i'll show you what we have come up
with
to address
to address each challenge
so
if you don't know
what the intensive care is i don't know
where you've been living for the past
two years
but basically is where patients that are
in critical conditions are treated now
this became very famous with covid but
even before covered a lot of patients go
to intensive care sometimes after
surgery but sometimes because of very
acute and sudden conditions
and an interesting thing is also that
patients are monitored continuously so
this is just a subset of everything that
is measured uh in the intensive care
some of these parameters so in my
presentation i will talk about
parameters and i mean clinical
parameters so each of these is a
parameter
some are measured every day but some are
even measured every minute so
obviously
implementing software in the icu has
great potential because it really is a
critical environment where you can make
very
important decisions um and there is a
lot of data and you also have very nice
stock photos for our business people to
to be excited about our products
um
so this is a screenshot of our software
so this is something that doctors look
at
when
this is integrated in their in their
software when they they look at a
patient
or in this case are the set of patients
and these are all the patients that are
currently in the intensive care
so you see here
patient information
and this is the outcome measure that we
so this is the main information that we
provide the doctors and is basically the
risk
that if the patient is discharged so
it's sent away from the intensive care
whether home or usually to another word
of the hospital
the risk that that patient is going to
come back to the icu
or that the patient will die within
seven days
this actually happens very often so for
an average hospital about six percent of
patients die or get readmitted which is
obviously
very bad for the patient and for the
hospital because we occupy uh extra beds
uh and extra costs and so on
and then we provide other information
which i'm going to talk about a bit
later
such as whether the patient is currently
on life support because that influences
that this influences the decision of
whether the patient can be discharged or
not
when you click on a patient this is what
you get so you see here the curve of the
probability of readmission
and mortality over time um and then here
we really try to explain what the model
uh is doing as much as possible so these
are the features
and we try to tell the doctor okay this
feature contributed positively or
negatively to the prediction uh by the
way these are all fake patients so don't
worry um this is the current prediction
and we also have to give a big red
warning saying look these features are
just
a correlation with the outcome they're
not a causal um there's no causal
relationship so don't try to increase
the sodium in the patient blood thinking
that this is going to improve the
condition you'd be surprised you know
if it's there there's a reason why it's
there
just a quick overview of the software
it's not super important but it's gonna
i just want to give you an idea of how
the data flows um so we offer both cloud
and on-premise installation and the
important part is
this part here which is how the data
flows from the electronic health record
of the syst of the hospital
um to an intermediate database that we
can access to then all our
etl pipeline feature engineering
prediction
and frontend so this is how the data
flows from the hospital to the hospital
again
eventually in the front end that i just
showed you it will become
important in a second
so this is an overview of how the
software works
now once this is implemented as i said
at the beginning it's very important
that we are sure that the predictions
that we provide to the doctors are
are safe are usable
that they're not going to make decisions
based on faulty data
now
the first
concept is data validity so how can we
ensure that the data we process is valid
and correct
the second one is interpretability and
auditability can we explain why the
model
gave a certain prediction
and the third one is prediction validity
so
given a certain prediction
can we sure that that prediction is
is valid and can we trust it and can or
should the doctor use it to actually
make a certain decision
so let's talk about data validity first
now
we identified three main areas there are
more but i think it is a good
generalization
so the first one is data drift second
one is data extraction errors and
registration errors
back to the diagram of our software
this is a simplified version this is
what when we install the software on
premise so we don't have a lot of
components that are needed when we
install it in the cloud
this is what we develop and maintain so
from the database that the hospital
maintains we then extract the data we
map it we process it we create features
we do the predictions and yada yada so
we are pretty confident in this this
works we have all our tests all our
integration tests system tests and so on
but what happens there so the hospital
we obviously cannot access the data from
the same database that the hospital
software acts directly um
i mean i say obviously but this is
usually the case so what they do they
extract the data for us and put it into
an intermediate database and obviously
these are all i keep saying obviously
it's not that obvious but this
this whole infrastructure is created and
maintained by the hospital so we have no
idea what's going on there but errors
can happen and do happen so how do we
how do we monitor that without being
able to monitor the infrastructure
so the first concept is data drift i'm
sure you are all very familiar with it
so is the changes in data distribution
so in the distribution of the parameters
over time
an example so
due to covid uh patients in the acu's
recently in the past year or two are
very different from all the patients
that
were in the icu in the past so if you
train a model on patients from 2006 to
2018 and we try to apply to current
patients
then we will have problems one example
for example
patients with covet might have a much
higher respiration rate because they
they struggle with uh with breathing um
and while in the past these were this
was correlated with a negative outcome
uh it's not necessarily the case for
covet patients so the model will have
learned that a certain feature is
correlated with negative outcome
but then this is not the case and you
have a very skewed distribution of the
data that is different from
from the training data
the second one so and this one is not
really anyone's fault it's just things
that happen
but we can't fix this we just being able
we just be able to know that
that it happens to then
do something about it
this is registration changes so
these are all the changes that the
hospital does to how they record data
and they store data so for instance um
the hospital starts registering heart
rate with a completely new parameter id
and a new parameter name uh this
parameter id didn't exist when we
performed all the mapping of the
parameters at the beginning so suddenly
we don't have any more heart rate we
don't know where the heart rate went um
they forgot to tell us and now uh the
model thinks that hardware is not
measured for any patient
and obviously the performance would drop
massively
the third one is data extraction errors
um
so while the
the previous one wasn't actually a bug
uh this would include for example okay
they change a name in one of their
tables in their back end so the scripts
that they use to produce the
intermediate database then we query
don't work anymore and suddenly we don't
have any more medications in our in our
database this happened two weeks ago
and suddenly what no patient is giving
medications anymore so they're all very
healthy and then the softness are saying
yep everyone can be discharged nowhere
is
fun
um
so what we did we built a very simple
and very ugly dashboard
using flask this is a really very simple
one but it's very effective so what we
do we have all the parameters here
and we monitor for example the
distribution of the parameters in recent
past with the distribution
in the historical data so you see
for example the average value in the
past the 500 measurements
and the accepted range that is based on
some statistical
calculation
in the data that was used for training
the model
if it's red it means that it's outside
the acceptor range if it's green it
means that it's good
we also for example identify parameters
that haven't been measured recently this
was an addition after the medication
stable incident that i just told you
about so now if something is not there
for more than a few days it gets flagged
immediately so you see here we have
different uh different types of
parameters that are
monitored
similarly but not exactly
the same we can click on one of the
columns and we see the recent change in
distribution these are the limits so
this parameter is actually uh pretty
okay it's within the accepted ranges
and we can see also the distribution
um of the parameter in case we need to
check for example for outliers or if it
uh if it makes sense and it's more or
less what we expect
example of a real problem
the average age for recent patients is
outside of the comp is an incompetent
confidence interval
so we click on the graph and we see this
so wow so the average age in current
this is real data from previous weeks
um
the average age of patients is much
lower than what we saw in the historical
data any guess
covet exactly
so
look at this right so we expect patients
in the icu to be more or less between
59 and 67 but now the average is quite a
few years younger interesting right so
if we use age as a parameter as a
feature of the model
um
this actually will tell the model that
patients
with covet are actually doing better
than they might be doing because they
have a lower age
we also have a tab for predictions so we
can look at how the predictions of the
model change over time
for example the prediction are
discharged the prediction in the last 24
hours before discharge and then all
predictions
and also here we see a nice an
interesting trend so the prediction at
discharge
uh the percentage of prediction and
discharge that were below a certain
threshold of one percent became less and
less so that means that the model is
giving higher and higher predictions
in the past few weeks this could mean a
lot of things
but it's good to know what's happening
to the trend in general
let me have a sip of water
so
next
we have interpretability and
auditability now we talk a lot about you
know explainable
models uh interpretability which is all
very true um
but particularly
when you work in a context that is very
sensitive not only for the life of
patients but also for legal reasons
so we need this first of all because the
doctors might actually want to know
um
what's happening why is the model giving
certain predictions to make more
informed decisions just a percentage
is not going to tell the doctors much so
already the giving them the future
importance is nice but we really want to
enable them to have a full
idea of why the model
decided to say seven percent and not
three percent
if something happens
we must be able to provide all the
information we can to any investigation
if a patient dies and the family
sues the hospital
they will come to us and say well
actually you gave this prediction so the
doctor discharged the patient because
they saw a low prediction but then the
patient died so we need to be able to
say look this is why the model said it
this is why the parameters of the
patients were this and this
um we need to show that we are fully
aware of what the model is doing
and also to
to put a model in production or software
in production in healthcare you need
certifications and when you get audited
when you apply for certification you
need to show that you are fully aware
and full in control of of what the model
is doing so in this case explainability
is not just a nice to have but it's
really a must-have
and so this is something that we built
with streamlit if you are a data
scientist and you can be bothered to do
any front-end work streamlet is great
it's very ugly but it works very well
amazingly ugly mad lib
plots but you can build this in 15
minutes it works it does what you have
to do
by the way something i forgot so both
the one before and this are for now for
internal monitoring so we don't
doctors don't access this it's for us to
make sure that everything is going well
um and the dashboard before will stay
like that whereas we would like what i'm
about to present now we would like to
also have
uh
to open up for the user the opportunity
to look at
each patient in depth and how the
prediction of the patient changed based
on the changing uh the changing features
so this is something that we show so you
can see the prediction over time
and this is we use shop for feature
importance i'm not going to go in
details about shop but i'm sure many of
you know it
and we show how different features
contribute differently to each
data point
and then we also show here the value of
the feature and how the future
importance varies with that with that
value
to give an example
you see this patient has had a quite low
prediction uh probability quite quite a
low probability and then it spikes up a
little bit
and we see that it's mostly due to these
two purple features here that weren't
here and then suddenly in the last three
times then they pop up so we're like
okay the doctor might want to know why
not only why the why is the probability
at this level now but why it went up
from a lower probability to a higher
probability
so if we look at these two graphs you
can look at the shop value so this is
basically a measure of future importance
future contribution
and of the feature value
so feature 9
is a measure of how awake the patient is
how responsive it is and it dropped in
value all of a sudden so the patient is
less responsive
the future importance increases means
that the probability of readmission and
mortality spikes up so dr seuss is like
ah now i understand because the patient
is less responsive for
various reasons
it the probability that if we were to
discharge this patient now um goes up
and similarly for this one this is
interesting so you see there was no
measured value for this feature
until here so the future importance was
done on an imputated value
but then as soon as the value is
measured
we have more information the feature
importance goes up the probability goes
up because this value is actually above
the median value for this blood blood
parameter i'm hiding the names of the
features because these are real patients
so it's we're trying to not uh not show
any
an individual case
just for privacy reasons
and then last prediction validity so now
we talked about
parameters features we want to monitor
that but then given that those are
correct can we be sure that the
prediction
predictions we make are are indeed valid
so
the sample that the model is trained on
can be very different from the
population on which the model is applied
to in practice so
can these different can this difference
really um
you know produce a bias that makes the
predictions invalid
to give an example this is how the
the training set looks like so we have
admissions that start at a given time
then we take the moment of discharge and
then the discharge can be either
successful or unsuccessful build a
classifier
we get a probability and then the model
is trained on this
in production however the model will
give a prediction at any given point
during the admission so we actually
provide the prediction every hour
but this prediction here is very far
from discharge and in the training set
we only have patients at discharge so
the doctors have given you know certain
medications have done certain actions to
prepare the patient for discharge so a
patient at this point here is
can be very different from a patient at
this point in terms of what they look
like in terms of values in terms of
interventions medications and so on so
we cannot really be sure that a
prediction here is is as valid as the
prediction given just before this charge
so in general when we talk about machine
learning
this can apply to a lot of other
contexts
we want to make sure that the instances
of observations in production are
similar enough to the training instances
then a prediction is valid and in the
case of our model we want to know are
the patients that are current in the icu
and for which the model is providing a
prediction right now are they similar
enough to patients that were discharged
in the training set at the moment of
discharge
so we have two main ways to make sure
that this happens
one is very simple so define business
rules
so domain domain knowledge basically we
sit with the doctors and we say okay
these are the rules that
if they're true then the patient is
considered similar enough
and the second one is out of domain
detection
so business rules means basically okay
when is a patient
eligible for discharge
if a patient is on life support so for
example is on dialysis is on is
intubated has some very strong
medications then those patients are
never discharged from the seu so by
definition they are too different from
patients that
were discharging training set and for
those we don't want the prediction to be
used
our domain is a bit more complex
in the sense that we want to also be
able to to find patients that are not
ready to be discharged without these
rules
and those can be done with certain
techniques like outlier detection
or density estimation and there is a
whole field of machine learning for this
and this is interesting because it can
also detect novel patient types so for
example if this model was in production
when coveted
it would be hopefully able to tell us
look the model has never seen this
patient don't trust this prediction or
at least you know be careful with it
so this is implemented in practice this
is still work in progress it's the next
step that we want to do
so it's uh
yeah it's it's soon to be implemented
this is the message that the user gets
when they click on a patient that is not
eligible for discharge so we tell them
the various causes that it could be so
they you see that here the prediction is
not shown
is because the patient
is in this case on life support so it's
both intubated he's getting medications
and is on dialysis
never going to be discharged so it's
actually no there's no point giving a
prediction not only because it's not
safe but also because it will
decrease the trust that the user has on
the software if the software says yeah
this patient can be discharged but the
doctor knows that the patient cannot be
discharged they will start losing trust
in the software and this especially for
doctor is a very very sensitive topic
we also monitor these business rules
these are the same dashboards before
these are the all the eligibility flags
so if any of this is true
we don't we don't provide a
prediction or we give a warning at least
and we have you know percentage of
patients in the last
60 or whatever that have this flag the
mean
length of the admission for which this
patient was
was under this rule so actually more
than half of the patients
are intubated at least once and for at
least half of their whole
stay in the icu
for if you're more interested if you're
interested more in what we do for
out of the main or out of distribution
detection you can check out this paper
um but
yeah it's uh it's online so you can find
it
now so we have all these uh all these
rules what happens if there is a problem
now i showed you a couple of cases okay
age is uh is too low um
we find that medications are not there
anymore what happens so just a couple of
cases
so if there is a data extraction error
or a data registration error so first
the very first thing we need to do is
contact the hospital and say look
this parameter is not there anymore
what's going on because we don't know
whether it's because they change the
registration it's because there is an
error
because they just stopped measuring a
certain
certain doing a certain blood test for
example that can also happen
and then depending on what they say we
then either need to ask them to fix it
or we need to add for example a raw to
the mapping of our extraction pipeline
data drift again this is no one's fault
uh we need to discuss with the doctors
to understand why there is this data
drift so you know the answer could be oh
well these are covet patients or
we stopped admitting patients with a
certain
disease and so on
and if deem appropriate we might need to
retrain the model because if that
the feature that uses a parameter that
is drifting a lot is very important for
the model then well the prediction is
not valid anymore so we might need to uh
to do a retraining we don't do live
retraining we always retrain
uh manually because we need to check a
lot of things so um yeah it's it's not a
good idea to do online training
what happens if we have an out of domain
prediction well i just showed you that
we just don't show the prediction in the
front end or we give a warning to the
doctor saying look this patient cannot
be discharged right now so be very
careful
what if a doctor flag flags a patient's
prediction as abnormal so we have a
feedback button we also want to put a
little flag an extra patient saying
i don't think that this is true
then we need to we want to enable them
to investigate the future contribution
and prediction to really understand why
the prediction was given
and what happens if the distribution of
the predictions start deviating from the
historical one so we know that the
average readmission and mortality rate
was about six percent what if suddenly
15 of our predictions
um are you know above 10 percent then we
really need to look at what caused this
uh is the model you know calibrated well
do we need to retrain it and basically
we look at all the above to try and find
uh the answers which are often
not very obvious
what's next so i already mentioned we
want to implement this out of domain
detection
as soon as possible because it's uh it's
very important
we want to automate at least some of the
warnings right now we only have the
dashboard so we need to check them
manually uh but maybe we want to get you
know an email when or you know maybe a
dashboard with all the warnings
this is difficult because we also need
to be careful uh with uh
with alarm fatigue so we don't want to
be warned for every single time a
parameter goes out of our distribution
we want to monitor features not only
parameters so for example all the
aggregated features that we use as
inputs in the model this is very easy
and just
didn't do it yet we want also the
monitor to also want to monitor the
missing text mappings so for example
some parameters have uh you know the
ventilation mode that you're on assisted
controlled spontaneous and so on they
use tens uh sometimes hundreds of
different
text parameters and we want to map them
to categories and sometimes they just
start using free text to do this and
then we don't know what that means and
so we need to also monitor those
monitoring the outcomes and concept
drift so this is when
um yeah really like the for example the
the way of working in the hospital
changes and so suddenly their admission
rate becomes much lower much higher
and then the model is not actually
reflecting practice anymore
and also something interesting would be
the correlation and interactions within
between features
so how features interact with each other
sometimes for example the ph in blood is
very highly correlated with the amount
of
carbon dioxide in your blood so if that
for example starts not being true
anymore it might mean that the patients
are different or the way they're treated
is different
so
to conclude um
errors in data extraction can lead to
unwanted model behavior
and that can happen because of changes
in data registration or bugs in the
hospitals code
and then we can have data drift due to
changing populations in the hospital
and that also can cause problems with
the model
and one of the big problems that is not
caused by errors is that the model will
provide predictions even though our
predictions are not needed or when the
prediction should not be used
and something that i want to highlight
again is that explainability of the
models is not only a nice thing to have
because you know everyone talks about it
but is without explainable models we
cannot go in production like it just
doesn't happen
so in conclusion a combination of ux
design monitoring
and mitigation processes so what to do
when problems are you know very clear
roles very clear responsibilities very
clear process
are needed to be there um to make sure
that we can implement uh we can
implement these models in the hospital
they can be used and they can be
effective and actually save lives and
not just you know be a nice
advertisement for for hospitals
so i think we have some time for q a
thanks
[Applause]
and i get to throw this which is uh
let's try
okay
uh
nice
uh i have a question about these uh ugly
matlob mudplot lip grafts that you
showed
i was wondering how much time do you
envision that one of those doctors would
be
taking to look at these feature
importances and make a decision
yeah this one for instance yep
it's very ugly
and and into an extension to that um
can you comment on the the challenge of
um yeah informing these doctors in
uh with data visualizations that they
might not be very familiar with in their
day-to-day job like how would that go
excellent question so we would never
show a doctor this exact plot yes um so
this is fully for us uh
implemented just for our own uh sort of
debugging
processes this is very complex
especially if you don't understand
feature importance if you don't
understand shop and so on so you see in
the front end
this was already quite hard to even show
just feature importance for
the current
prediction um
because you need to be able you know
these are actually aggregated features
so sometimes we have a feature like
standard deviation of this parameter in
the last 24 hours
how do you show it to a doctor right so
for example we decided to exclude
standard deviation features because we
cannot explain them so we now only use
for example the mean in the last on the
first 24 hours or overall
and we need to make it as humanly
readable as possible
to do it that way the reason why it's
not in the software is because we
haven't found a good way to do it and so
sometimes
well often there is a
like a balance between interpretability
and simplicity if interpretability makes
the software very complex they're not
going to use it if we don't have enough
interpretability they're also not going
to use it so there is a lot of user
testing and
there's actually a huge difference for
example between academic hospitals and
non-academic hospitals you go and do
your user testing in academic hospitals
like very cool oh i know shop yeah yeah
let's do this and then you go to a
normal hospital and they're like
wha wha
what's this number what percent i don't
understand and like really like they
don't understand they don't want to
understand they're not used to these
things
um so it's not easy uh and it is indeed
a challenge to a matter of labor
normally by meaningful use gg plot is
going to be prettier but not easier to
understand often
um so yeah if you have good ideas on
how to do it come find me afterwards
sorry
no no very good question you can uh
yeah pass it around
very nice presentation it's really cool
to see how far you guys have come in a
few years right yeah yeah
the whole the whole the the whole
deployment stuff there at interpret is
really cool one question i had about the
data is where do you train on is this
data from one hospital or is this
something you do for each hospital or
yeah
um so for legal reasons actually we can
only do it hospital per hospital
one of the
many things we researched in the past is
how to use for example the domain
adaptation and transfer learning to try
and you know use other hospitals without
pulling the data together by contracts
we're not allowed to pull data but even
if we were it doesn't always increase
the performance in the new hospitals so
we have to calibrate it hospital by
hospital so we have the software but
every time we want to go to new hospital
we have to retrain the model
so we know which features are more or
less uh you know the predictive ones but
it can really change because
for example in uh i don't know in the
in one hospital in amsterdam they have
half of their patients are cardiac
surgery patients those are patients stay
for 24 hours and then they leave almost
no one dies and then you go to i don't
know utrecht and they have you know 30
percent are neurosurgical patients those
are very difficult patients our model
doesn't work at all on your surgery
patients so what do you exclude them do
you retrain you calibrate
so yeah we do it hospital by hospital
cool
i think